-Let's get to
some news here, guys.
I heard that President Trump
wants to fire his
chief of staff, John Kelly.
Yeah, Kelly was shocked.
He was like, "Wait, I haven't
already been fired?
I mean, what's --
I still work here?"
[ Cheers and applause ]
There are also reports
that Trump wants to fire
his Homeland Security secretary,
Kirstjen Nielsen.
[ Audience oohs ]
When asked who he liked to run
Homeland Security,
Trump said, "Claire Danes.
She'd be perfect,
absolutely perfect."
Some more news here.
Today, Trump took part in
a ceremony to celebrate Diwali,
the Hindu festival of lights.
But at the event,
Trump had a little trouble
lighting a candle.
Watch this.
[ Camera shutters clicking ]
[ Laughter ]
Trump was like -- He's like,
"I got to be careful.
If this gets
anywhere near my hair,
the whole place
is going to blow.
Someone else do this."
Fwoo!
But since Diwali is India's
biggest holiday of the year,
Trump decided to release a video
wishing a happy Diwali
to several Indian cities.
Here, check this out.
[ As President Trump ]
I want to wish a happy Divali
to all the cities in India.
Cities like Del-hi.
[ Laughter ]
Coca-Cola.
Mambo No. 5.
Victoria Beckham.
Bang Al Gore.
And my personal favorite,
Spider-Man.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Normal voice ] He's trying.
I don't know.
-Come on.
He don't know no better.
-Here's a big story.
This morning, CNN filed a
lawsuit against President Trump.
When he found out, Trump was --
[ Cheers and applause ]
When he found out,
Trump was furious.
He was like, "Crap,
did I sleep with CNN?"
I thought we --
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's right, CNN filed
a lawsuit against Trump
for taking away reporter
Jim Acosta's press pass.
But this isn't the first time
the White House
has had trouble
with a press pass.
Listen to this.
I saw this on the news today.
-There have been sort of notable
problems with that process,
including in
the Bush administration
when they gave a --
regularly, gave a day pass
to someone who turned out
to be a male escort.
[ Laughter ]
-They knew something was up
when he was the only reporter
wearing tear-away pants
and a dog collar.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Who's that guy?
What network's he with?"
This is pretty cool.
There's a new pose
everyone's doing online
called the Instasplit.
You guys heard about this?
Here's Victoria Beckham
doing it.
And here's Katy Perry.
She did it.
And Kate Beckinsale did it,
yeah.
Pretty impressive.
Higgins, why don't you
give it a try?
-Sure.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-James, do you want
to give it a go?
-Don't think I can do that.
-Ah, come on,
just try it, buddy.
-Fine.
[ Grunts ]
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, yeah, hey.
Oh, my God. Oh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
How's he still
playing the piano?
I have no idea.
-[ Grunts ]
-My God.
Hey, I heard today
is World Kindness Day.
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
There's been a lot of negativity
in the world recently.
So in honor
of World Kindness Day,
I thought it would be good
if we went around
and said something nice
about each other.
I'll go first.
Tariq, we've known each other
for a few years.
And I have to say, not only are
you a really talented person,
you're also
a really great friend.
-Cool.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, it's your turn.
-Thanks, Jimmy.
[ Light laughter ]
-I mean, you could
say something.
You could say something now,
if you want.
-I did.
Thanks.
[ Laughter ]
-That's it?
-Yeah.
-Nothing else to add?
-Um, okay.
Nice tie.
[ Laughter ]
-That's it?
-Yeah.
-Just that?
Nothing else?
-Yeah, I'm good.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, well, I meant
everything I said.
-Cool.
[ Laughter ]
-Nothing?
You have nothing else to say?
-I mean, let me think.
No.
-But we're in front
of all these people.
And I'm sure they'd like to hear
some kindness right now.
Right, guys?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I think they want
to hear jokes.
-No, they don't!
They want to hear you
say something kind.
-Fine.
Hey, James, I appreciate you.
-No, no, no.
Screw James.
I'm talking about me!
-What did I do?
[ Light laughter ]
-Yeah, Jimmy,
that wasn't very kind.
-Eh, shut up.
-You shut up.
-No, you shut up.
-I'll shut up when you shut up.
-No, you.
-No, you!
-No, you shut up!
-Happy World Kindness Day
from your friends at NBC.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow.
I'm going for the Emmy,
you guys.
You guys hear about this?
Mattel just came out
with a new Magic 8-Ball
called the Trump Magic 8-Ball.
It's like a Magic 8-Ball
but with Trump
answering your questions.
Well, good news is
we actually have one.
And he's going to answer
your questions right now.
It's time for
"Trump Magic 8-Ball."
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪♪ Trump Magic 8-Ball ♪♪
♪♪ Trump Magic 8-Ball ♪♪
-Welcome to
"Trump Magic 8-Ball."
This Magic 8-Ball is filled with
the wisdom of President Trump.
You can ask it
any personal question you want
as long as it's
a yes or no question.
Then you give it a shake.
And the President
of the United States
will answer your question.
Who wants to give it a try?
Come on.
Anybody?
There you go.
You, there you go.
Stand up.
How you doing, buddy?
You can take that.
How you doing?
What's your name?
-Rasmus.
-Rasmus?
-Yeah.
-Hey, welcome to the show,
Rasmus.
What is a personal question
you would like to ask
the Trump Magic 8-Ball?
-Um, what do you eat
for breakfast?
[ Laughter ]
Oh, is it the 8-Ball or him?
-Well, no,
it's a yes or no answer.
So you could be like,
"Did I eat breakfast?"
Or...
[ Laughter ]
Would you -- Yeah.
Would you like to eat sausage
for breakfast?
Something like that.
The answer has to be yes or no.
-Okay, okay.
Do you like English breakfast?
-Okay, there you go.
Let's hear what the President
has to say,
if you want to hear this.
-I mean, yeah, I guess.
Why not?
-There you go.
Perfect, unbelievable.
Thank you, Rasmus.
Appreciate it.
Anyone else?
Yes. Hi.
Get over here.
Take your time.
Here you go. Hey.
-Hi.
-How you doing?
-Big fan.
-Hey, I'm a fan of yours.
How you doing?
What's your name?
-Anupama.
-Anupama, where you from?
-Well, Jersey City.
-Hey.
Jersey City.
-I was born and raised in Nepal,
though.
-Is that right?
-Yeah.
-Well, thank you for being
on the show tonight.
You can ask any question
you want.
And the Trump Magic 8-Ball
will answer.
Do you have -- What question
would you like to ask?
-Can I take a second?
-Sure.
-Okay.
All right, I'm ready.
-Okay, perfect.
It really was --
You were really accurate.
It was one second.
All right, here we go.
Go ahead, ask.
-Will I win
the next mega billion?
-Will you win
What does the Trump
Magic 8-Ball say?
-The odds are aren't looking
so great right now.
-I'm so sorry about that.
Well, it's just --
Sorry.
It's not completely accurate.
I mean, he doesn't like
English breakfast, either.
Anybody up here?
Yeah, get over here.
Come on.
Sure.
You can stand there if you want.
Yeah, sure.
What's your name?
-Emily.
-Emily, where you from?
-Pennsylvania.
But I live here in New York.
-But you here in New York?
-Yeah.
-Hey, thanks for being here.
Emily, what is the question
you would like to ask
the Trump Magic 8-Ball?
-Will you please resign?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Are you going to resign?
-To me this is
a very, very sexy subject.
I find it sexy.
-There you go.
That's all the time we have
for the "Trump Magic 8-Ball."
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's a very sexy subject.
Guys, I read that
New York street food vendors
are going to get letter grades
from the health inspector
starting next month.
Yeah, which means
we all have 30 more days
to enjoy hot dogs
for the very last time.
Not going to --
Not gonna be good.
That's right, health inspectors
will give New York street
food vendors letter grades.
So if you see a street car with
the letters "A," "B," or "C,"
that's just the type
of hepatitis you'll get.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, I saw that Monopoly
just released a new version
of their game
called Monopoly for Millennials.
It's just like the original
except everyone starts
with $60,000 of college debt.
We have a great show tonight.
Give it up for the Roots.